the Targaryen is used dragonglass to
decorate the weapons without even
knowing what the first men used it for
see that sword
it's called hearts bein been in our
family for five hundred years its
Valyrian steel only a handful of them
left in the world supposed to go to my
firstborn son after I died your father
gave me this change the pommel from a
pair to a wolf
very still Longclaw
hey everybody new Game of Thrones
everyone's requested a video on all the
Valyrian swords that are on the TV show
right now also including things that are
Valyrian weapons but aren't necessarily
swords like Arya's dagger or even one of
Daenerys as Dothraki allies in the books
has a Valyrian steel Iraq this design
like their traditional weapons as you
can see from those clips the shows
actually taking a lot of time to explain
why is so special so I'll try to explain
what's going on but if you are finding
me for the first time I do Game of
Thrones every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything
they'll be giveaway step I'll explain at
the end of the video too so you have all
these moments in the preceding seasons
but you get to season seven and they
spend most of it talking about
dragonglass with a few brief moments
just showing the audience how special
Valyrian steel is like it may have been
a deleted scene but after Jon Snow tried
to give a long claw back to Jorah
Mormont and he was like no no no may
this protect you in your house for many
generations to come he never told Jorah
hey this can actually be used to kill
the thing that's trying to kill us but
the good thing about Jorah Mormont is
that he's an anointed Knight he's a
smart person so he noticed what the
sword was able to do so I think he put
two and two together but I think the
reason why the show just completely
omitted the words Valyrian steel from
season 7 is because they wanted you to
focus on the dragon glass and how it
could be used to fight the army of the
Dead and there have been a couple rule
changes about what can kill the whites
what can kill the White Walkers and then
obviously on top of that we have undead
vissarion so I think it stands to reason
that the same things that can kill White
Walkers can also kill vissarion it's
just that he's so much bigger and
they're setting him up like this amazing
threat that I would be very surprised if
all it took was like a little sliver of
Valyrian steel or a little sliver of
dragon glass to kill that giant undead
dragon that would be a big
disappointment but the whole thing about
Valyrian steel is that is actually based
on Damascus steel some of you are really
big weapon buffs but the mystery on the
TV show and in the books is they haven't
revealed the secret of Valyrian steel
now it's probably similar to Damascus
steel but the whole idea is the Sam
wells reading this book about how the
Targaryens used dragon glass to adorn
their weapons without really knowing
what the first men used it for so
I think the funny reveal is that
everything about the Valyrian culture
their weapons their dragons were
designed for fighting white walkers in
the long night without realizing it
because just charting the time line the
rise of the Valyrian freehold happened
after the first long night so Valyrians
were taming dragons right around the
time the wall was beginning to be built
so if you're wondering if these special
swords existed during the first long
night they did not so that also raises
some interesting questions about the
idea of the original light bringer like
light bringer everybody used to think
was a special sword to be one of the
Valyrian swords but if Valyrian swords
didn't exist during the first long night
then what was a Zora highest light
bringer maybe it was just some regular
sword or some special dragonglass weapon
the TV show has been over backwards to
make them look amazing they even produce
like a special small segment narrated by
Sir Jorah Mormont so actually play this
here this is from I think the season
four DVDs as advanced design is from
bronze so is Valyrian steel from
ordinary steel lighter yet stronger and
nothing holds an edge like it if you
take a whetstone to a Valyrian blade
you'll need another whetstone and maybe
another hand to hold it nobody knows how
the Valyrians forged their steel less
than a handful of Smith's can now even
reshape it the process like so much of
their civilization was lost in the doom
when he claimed they wove magic spells
into the molten metal and blasted it
with dragon fire when you see a Valyrian
blade smoky and dark as if drinking in
the Sun and rippling with a thousand
folds you may not scoff so loudly the
Valyrian steel that exists now is all
that will ever be some survives in the
Citadel with the maesters chains were a
link of Valyrian steel signifies study
of the higher mysteries whatever those
are some drifts through the world as
prized daggers and jewelry for rich
merchants
I've even seen a Dothraki arek so that
explains a little bit about the myths of
Valyrian steel but I think the funny
thing there they sort of tip their hat
to what you probably need to do to
create new Valyrian steel
you need dragon fire probably dragon
glasses Samwell narrates as he's reading
his books in regular steel so even
though we only have six episodes left
there are a lot of theories that they
might try to create some new Valyrian
steel using Daenerys dragons but I think
the idea is is that the future of Game
of Thrones there will be more dragons
there will be a dream of spring they'll
eventually learn these techniques again
otherwise they wouldn't have gone
through the trouble of explaining how
the Targaryens combined dragon glass
with their regular structures how they
would weave it into everything they had
part of the idea of season seven wasn't
discovering lost knowledge or knowledge
that was thought to be lost so currently
on the TV show we only have a fraction
of the Valyrian steel swords that are
still around in the story in the books
there's other swords that exist but we
just haven't had those characters on the
TV show yet so Jon Snow still has long
claw ancestral blade of house Morman
he'll probably continue to use that til
the end of the show I know there's
another special Targaryen sword that
I'll talk about in a second called black
fire which is still thought to be lost
in the East it was taken to the east by
the surviving black fires bittersteel
when they formed the golden company and
that all we know is that it was just
last seen with them we don't know who
has it right now so it's still floating
around in the east somewhere along with
bright roar the ancestral blade of House
Lannister so there have been swords that
have been lost over time but also on the
TV show now we have Arya with her
Valyrian dagger we don't know what its
official name is it probably does have a
name or Arya will give it a name during
season eight and I know we're all really
hoping that Arya decides to surprise
name her Valyrian steel dagger dark
sister even though that would be a bit
of fanservice because that's the name of
the ancestral Targaryen blade that was
wielded by one of agon sisters that was
then passed down through generations
until it was wielded by the Bloodraven
who then gave his powers to bran
so maybe now that bran has the sum total
of all knowledge in Westeros probably
the world
maybe Samwell will use that to his
advantage and we'll learn a little bit
more about balerion steel
and then probably the most interesting
blade that we have on the TV show right
now is still ice the two halves of ice
Jaime and Brienne widows wail in earth
keeper now you know why they gave that
sword to Jamie on the TV show he's going
to need something that can kill White
Walkers and then Samwell still has
heart's pain even though I don't think
anyone expects him to actually fight on
the front lines so then why you ask why
would he steal that blade if they
weren't gonna do anything with it during
season seven that's why I think they're
saving some of the mythology surrounding
the creation of Valyrian steel for
season eight
because Samwell is just grabbing all the
things he thinks are necessary so even
if Samwell isn't going to be using
hearts pain he'll probably give it to
someone else who is fighting on the
front lines but if I had to pick who he
would give it to I would say either the
Hound depending on how quickly he goes
back to the north or bran because both
of them will definitely be doing a lot
of fighting anyone you know who is an
awesome fighter and is still alive in
season eight up in the north is gonna
spend most of that season fighting White
Walkers and the undead really big bonus
- this is actually exciting but in the
books the damp air actually hallucinates
your on wearing Valyrian steel armor now
it's just a hallucination he's having a
vision of something that might wind up
happening but in it he's also sitting on
the Iron Throne so I think it's meant to
be this vision of what would happen
should Iran get what he wants and he
does have the balerion steel horned
dragon binder but I don't think we'll
see the horn on the TV show magic horns
themselves are actually a really big
thing in the books I don't think the TV
show is gonna get into like there's not
a lot of magic when you get into
Valyrian steel on the TV show most of
their time is spent just hyping up how
resilient it is compared to normal steel
but that's actually another good
question do you think that we'll see
Samwell reading about the more magical
properties that Valyrian 'sm Bude their
weapons with but congratulations to last
week's DVD giveaway winner Mac F please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details I'm giving away copies of the
season 7 DVD all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video so you can click here for
brand-new Game of Thrones and you can
click here for my non-spoiler e Star
Trek discovery episode 1 review thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you